hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the latest
huge reveals in the black clover story
asta's secret origins the truth
about his mother and the devil's real
hidden form all of these things have
been either revealed
or heavily implied in the latest
installment of the story
and i'll say it right now i did not see
this coming
there is so much to talk about this is
totally crazy
so let's get into it if you enjoy the
black clover content here on the channel
and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed please
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications by the way we've
started live reacting to the latest
leaks for black clover
and other series over on our twitch
channel
if you'd like to chat with us about the
latest reveals before we even publish
our videos here on the youtube channel
definitely follow us on twitch right now
twitch.tv slash
animeopror or click the top link down
in the description and as if i have to
say it but this video will include black
clover manga spoilers we're talking
about the latest developments in the
story so please proceed with caution you
have been warned
now let's go back to the final page of
the previous chapter
when i saw that panel of a face that
looked a lot like
osta's being surrounded by demonic
darkness
i just assumed that this was asta being
taken over
by the anti-magic devil even though this
face looked a lot like asta
it definitely had some clear differences
like the ears and the teeth
but i just assumed that this was the
devil changing asta's appearance
as he took over kind of like the members
of the dark triad
whose appearance changes based on how
much of their devil's power they
actually use
at the time it didn't even cross my mind
that something
else could be going on here until i saw
several comments
on my previous black clover video in
these comments you guys pointed out that
maybe this wasn't the devil taking
over asta maybe this was the devil
revealing his true
form and he just happens to look a lot
like
osta this was too crazy for me to even
consider like
why in the world would the devil look
like osta but as it turns out
the people who made those comments were
absolutely right
that wasn't the devil taking over
austin's body that was the devil
emerging
into the physical world and revealing
his true
form huge congrats to everyone who got
that
right osta's devil in his true form
laughs menacingly and then he says how
he hasn't been
here in a while i presume that in this
context
here means the physical world because we
can now see that asta's devil
is standing across the room from asta
himself
they are now two separate entities
within
the physical world and it's actually
kind of funny because the devil looks
like he could be
osta's evil lost twin or something like
that
but instead of being scared or freaked
out by the devil's sudden appearance
asta says that there is something that
he has been wanting to say to the devil
for a long time
and what asta wanted to tell him was
thank you
the devil is confused by this he was
expecting
osta to be scared of him not to thank
him but osta explains that the power of
the anti-magic devil has saved him
countless times and not just him but
also his friends
since asta was born without magic the
devil's power is pretty much the only
reason why he's been able to follow his
dream and become
a magic knight and for this reason asta
offers his sincere thanks to the devil
the devil then reminds osta that he just
recently took his right arm
but asta replies that he has no
complaints they both agreed that asta
would make that sacrifice
and osta accepted it willingly so he
doesn't blame the devil or hold a grudge
the devil is still confused by osta's
unexpectedly
positive attitude towards him and he
then goes on to call
osta stupid he even threatens osta
telling him that he is about to die
at the hands of the devil the anti-magic
devil then
activates the grimoire on his own and
takes possession
of the demon slayer sword asta can't do
much more than
watch helplessly as his own devil
attacks him
out in the physical world without the
devil's anti-magic power
asta has no magic of his own so all he
can do is use his physical strength to
dodge the devil's attacks physical
strength is
all he's got and now even that is
jeopardized since he no longer has use
of one of his limbs
the devil proclaims that asta's right
arm is only the beginning
the devil will take everything from asta
but even after all of this taunting by
the devil asta
isn't even trying to fight he wants the
devil to stop
and listen to him asta doesn't want to
fight he wants to
talk knocked warns astha that he has to
fight
he came here to get stronger and he has
to fight and win
if foster loses the devil will take over
his entire body
and his body will become so corrupt by
the devil that it will become a demonic
monster this reminds me of leaked and
how his soul became corrupted by
forbidden magic until he transformed
into that gigantic
demon thing apparently the ritual that
asta is attempting to perform now
the creation of a formal contract with
his devil
in order to get stronger is something
that many have attempted in the past
and most have failed miserably what's
more this failure
cost them their lives the ritual in
question requires forbidden magic
and as we know from the example of
leaked and even secret
forbidden magic has serious consequences
at this point asta isn't sure if he
should even go through with the ritual
he knows that forbidden magic is very
dangerous and not something to play
around with
but knocked tells him that they only
have two days
there is no way for asta to become
strong enough within the next two days
to take on the dark triad he just can't
do it with any conventional form
of training in order to really become
stronger this quickly
asta must perform the ritual he must
form a contract
with his devil so he must either defeat
his devil
and tame him in some way or he will be
destroyed
by his own devil there is no third
option here
at least that's what noct wants austin
to think
as the devil attacks osta yet again
knocked
warns him one more time that if he
doesn't fight back and if he just keeps
dodging
asta will die but osta says
no and he goes on to say something
very interesting according to osta
his devil isn't really trying to kill
him
using his ability to sense ki osta can
tell that the anti-magic devil
is actually going easy on him he isn't
trying to really hurt
him nacht tells asta that he must be
confused
because the creature standing before him
is a devil
and devils have no conscience there is
no reason for a devil to feel compassion
for a human being or to show mercy
to a human the devil laughs and agrees
with knocked
proclaiming that devils are scumbags
but despite this idea that all devils
are inherently evil and cruel towards
humans
asta can tell that this devil is
different
there is something about him that
separates him from zagred
and the other evil devils according to
asta
just being a devil doesn't make him a
bad guy and asta firmly believes that
the anti-magic devil
isn't bad this again comes back to that
whole idea of prejudice
and how people in the world of black
clover are often judged
just based on their social status just
like all
commoners are judged and dismissed by
the nobles
it seems that the devils are all
collectively judged and dismissed as
evil by humans however asta clearly
believes that not
all devils are the same as asta is
saying all of these things
the anti-magic devil thinks back to what
looks like a distant
memory sometime in the past a woman who
looks
a lot like asta told the devil
the very same thing just like asta
she told him that he wasn't a bad guy
and that is how this unbelievable
chapter
ends and of course the question that we
are all asking
at this point is whether this woman is
osta's mother this definitely could be
asta's mother
she looks a lot like him and is this the
same woman from chapter 242
the woman who was seen only partially
and who was clearly bleeding from a
wound on her chest
and who said my dear son as she reached
out towards someone
and that someone could very likely be
a baby asta and if so what is the
devil's connection
to this woman why does the devil have
memories of her
and why does he remember casually
speaking to her somewhere
out in nature it's pretty clear that yes
this is the same woman from chapter 242
this woman's hair and clothing match the
woman from chapter 242
just look at the collar and you'll see
what i mean the woman from chapter 242
had clearly been injured
around the chest area and when i first
saw her i assumed that she was speaking
to asta when she said
my dear son i assumed that this was
asta's memory from back when he was a
baby
and that maybe asta's mother was a
subject of the spade kingdom who was
killed while trying to stop the dark
triads takeover
that would explain why asta ended up as
an orphan
right next to uno if he also lost his
parents during the dark triad takeover
it would make sense that he would end up
as an orphan right alongside yuno
but if this was osta's mother then why
does the devil have memories of her
and why does the devil also look like
osta could the devil have been this
woman's lover
and could he be osta's father
that would be absolutely insane and it
would explain
a lot of things it would explain why
asta was born without
magic his father is the anti-magic devil
so his genes are
incompatible with magic it would also
explain why
ostey in particular was chosen by the
five-leaf grimoire
it wasn't just a coincidence it was a
blood
connection and of course if this devil
really is asta's father
then it makes sense that the two of them
would look alike but
even though this is a very interesting
theory and i personally like it
we would have to assume that a devil can
actually have a child
with a human we still know very little
about the biology of the devils so we
can't say with certainty
whether that is really the case but
perhaps the anti-magic devil is actually
someone who used to be a human
we don't know how the devils are
actually born are they a species of
their own
or could they maybe be former humans who
were corrupted by forbidden magic to
such an extent
that they turned into devils could
asta's father be a human
who became a devil after he used
forbidden magic
maybe in an attempt to save osta's
mother
we saw that she was gravely injured
clearly her life was in mortal danger
so maybe asta's father sold his soul in
order to become a devil
in an attempt to protect her if the
anti-magic devil
really is osta's father then we know why
he was so
mad at dante the reason why the
anti-magic devil hates dante and lucifer
so much
could be that dante was the one who hurt
osta's mom
dante could be the one who killed her
during their takeover of the spade
kingdom
and so maybe the anti-magic devil became
furious after he and asked a loss to
dante
because he wants revenge against dante
for what he did
to asta's mother we will need more
information in order to know for sure
but this idea that the mystery woman is
asta's mother is very plausible
and since the devil clearly has some
connection with her
it is also possible that he could be
osta's father
which would be incredible but still we
can't jump to conclusions since for all
we know
the devil could be related to asta in
some other way
for example he could be a lost twin or
an ancestor
or something else man i honestly can't
wait to find out what happens in the
next
chapter this is so hype and so freaking
crazy
definitely let me know what you guys
think is this woman
osta's mother is the devil asta's father
and if not what is the devil's
connection to this woman
and what are his true intentions towards
asta
let me know down below if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
black lover content right here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know
it really does help and if you're new to
the channel or you just haven't
subscribed
definitely subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications black clover is just
so exciting right now so you definitely
want to stay tuned
to this channel we have many more videos
on black clover
coming soon don't forget to follow us on
twitch twitch.tv
animeopror if you want to talk about the
leaks as they come out
and talk to us live these streams will
happen before
our videos come out here on the channel
so definitely check it out
link in the description i want to give a
big thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons for making videos
like this one
possible a special thank you to alpha
sigma
and liam thompson disciples of lord
twego
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one-tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
jonathan king
rathuindeora emperor otaku thomas jones
kin mano
admirath and chris torley finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
king zeldris anatoly kazatsuki angel
crews
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
octor hinokamian water
bonnie parks jason wilson florian joy
and garcia
steelers mcshamus jessica kayla fond
deadly saint
stern hawkings and high school dxd73
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you
consider becoming a patron even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you